[Music] That's
amazing, but
stop it. Did you know? I'm telling you to
stop. [Music] Die! You won't be able to come back.
That's what I thought. Don't let it
out. Stay away from me. I can't
overcome the strong winds. I don't have
batteries. I wo
n't let you get in the
way.
Why are the two of you
leaving the ring behind, going
about your business, and forming a circle in the middle?
This would have been a big deal if there was a master. Why don't you just cover yourself with water and
reflect on yourself? Why do
n't you leave it there in the spring?  My younger
brother and child are crying.Teacher, I'm
sorry to both of you for getting so upset.Boss, let's
go back.